The value of x that makes this original equation true is positive 9. Way to go
if you got that one correct. It was tough. We can undo the square root on the
left and undo the square root on the right by squaring both sides of our
equation. And this is the step where you might have gotten stuck. We need to
square this 2, and square this radical. 2 squared equals 4, and the square root
of x squared is just x. This is why we'll have 4x on the left, and 3x plus 9 on
the right. Next we can subtract 3x from both sides to get 1x is equal to
positive 9. And finally, we want to check x equals 9 in the original equation
to be sure we have the correct answer. Substituting 9 in here and here, will
get this expression, which evaluates 0. Since 0 does equal 0, this solution
checks and you can be sure that is our correct answer.